Hello?
Hello, Amanda.
How are you doing this evening?
Good.
How about you?
I'm fine, too.
Thank you.
I'm so excited.
I'm making a plan for the summer vacation.
Really?
Sounds great!
What is your plan?
I'm planning to go to New Zealand!
Wow.
That's great!
So, when are you leaving?
In a month.
I can't wait to go.
How long are you staying there?
I'll be there for three weeks.
That's pretty long.
Where in New Zealand are you staying?
I will stay in Queenstown.
Oh, I see.
What will you do in Queenstown?
I will go bungee jumping.
It's a very popular activity there.
Aren't you scared?
I'm quite brave!
It will be fun!
Yeah.
It sounds very exciting.
Don't forget to bring me a souvenir.
Do you have anything particular in mind?
Anything traditional will do!